So how do we implement
reusable barriers correctly?
This is how.
The idea here is that the value for
releasing the barrier will not be the
same for all instances of the barrier.
Even instances when
release becomes zero,
all instances are going to
release when release becomes one.
So the idea is that we never really
need to reinitialize the release.
We just flip the release.
Each thread now has a localSense,
which is kind of what's the release
that we should get in order to get out?
So if we have 2 threads, 0 and 1,
let's say that they started
with localSense being 0.
Now they're going to get here and
they're both going to figure
out that the localSense is 1.
localSense is local to each thread, so
each of them just sets a local
variable independently.
So, this is not going to
interfere with each other.
Now, one of the thread will enter
the counter lock, increment the count,
and here if the count is equal to the
total, they will reset the count, and
set the release to localSense.
So it sets the release to
what we are waiting for,
in this case,
let's say thread one releases it to one.
That means that thread 0,
when it incremented account, didn't
see the total at 2, it saw it at 1,
and proceeded to exit here and
enters this wait here.
It's waiting now for
the release to become what it
thinks localSense is which is 1.
So it's going to spin until
somebody puts 1 into the release.
Eventually, thread 1 does that.
So now let's say that
thread 0 is stuck here,
that was the problem with the previous
implementation of the barrier.
Let's say that we just
don't read it fast enough.
So we want to see a 1, but
we don't check it fast enough.
Thread 1, now, proceeds to exit,
finishes the work and
comes back to the second
instance of the barrier.
It now flips its own localSense to 0.
Increments that count to 1,
because we reset the count when we were
releasing the first instance,
checks the count, sees that it is 1,
doesn't do this, unlocks the lock,
and enters the spin here.
But thread 1 is now checking
whether the release has become 0,
because it flipped the localSense.
Now it's waiting for this value for
the release, so they're waiting for
different value.
Note that the release is still the same
as thread 1 left it in
the first instance.
So eventually thread 0 will check and
see that the release has become 1,
at which point it will leave.
Eventually it's going to come here,
change its local sense to 0,
increment the count,
see that it's 2, reset the count,
set the release to 0 this time,
and now thread 1 will be released.
So by flipping the value of the release
instead of reinitializing it in each
iteration of the loop,
we avoid the problem that we had.
So this barrier is reusable.
We can synchronize on
the same barrier over and
over without risking
that lock situations.